Wow that was terrific that was amazing I
wasn't really I was also watching I love
new media and I just I'm watching
Lawrence of Arabia it's just awesome the
cinematography is chess I'll tell you to
really appreciate it you have to see it
in the widescreen
let me just oh yeah that's all those are
camels that's cool one of our next
presenters is one of the funniest people
I have ever met in my entire life and I
believe she's being joined by Steve
Carell
please welcome Anne Hathaway and Steve
Carell
thank you John for that kind
introduction you never cease to amaze me
with your constant need for attention
the topics they tackle are as diverse as
they are important political repression
in Iran the grueling and vicious
competition in the world of sports a
scathing indictment of health code
violations in the restaurant industry
these searingly painful documentaries
are both tragic we're doing animated
features a cute little rat chubby would
be surfing penguins what about the girl
I'm around uh animated Steve you know
serious subject but but animated
characters not the doc not not real this
is not documentary I do you read the
script no how many people are watching
this oh I just don't know wait hundred
billions my baby sick might even be sick
hold that thought it's just being shown
in Belgium we Oh we'll get through this
I'm gonna do the nominees now okay no
all right keep it together the nominees
for best animated feature film are okay
Persepolis Marjan satrapy and Vincent
para no ratatouille Brad Bird Surf's Up
ash Brannon and Krista